stabbings stabbing stabbing stabbings
they are the commonest cause of death
and the person most likely to stab you
is a friend or a relative
[Music]
there is a very simple step that
occurred
took me from nowhere to forensic
pathology in the space of about two
hours
friend of mine's father was a general
practitioner and in his office he
obviously had lots of medical textbooks
and one of those textbooks my friend had
spotted it was a textbook called
forensic Medicine by a man called Keith
Simpson and in it were all sorts of
photographs of dead bodies it just
amazed me that doctors could help the
police and the courts to establish why
people had died you know I thought
doctors made people better that's what
doctors did but suddenly here was
another role for doctors that really
really interested me
can you explain to me what a forensic
pathologist actually does right
a forensic pathologist a
helps the police
he helps the coroner who is the person
who is actually in charge of all sudden
and unexplained deaths in England and
Wales you know some people are
known that they're going to die some
people are in a hospice perhaps if I
could take the queen she was 96 it was
quite clear she was going to die in the
relative near future I mean not that day
maybe not the time when she actually did
die but at some point very soon at that
age 96 year olds very few of them go on
to live much longer but an Unexpected
death is one where you look round and
you go there's no good reason why this
person
should have died at this time and so we
need to investigate that death
and we do this by examining the body we
look the external surface of the body we
look at the internal organs of the body
we sometimes take samples of those
organs to look at them under a
microscope we sometimes take samples of
blood and of urine of liver of other
tissues to examine to see if there's any
drugs present and then we build up this
picture how and why did this person die
so important that everyone understands
the family and Society know why their
members have died and it's building this
puzzle up so we do it by looking at all
of those different aspects maybe we'll
go and examine the scene where the
person was found dead maybe we'll go and
examine the vehicle if they've been
involved in a road traffic accident
we'll try and see what the points of
damage inside outside and around the
vehicle work so all of these things it's
building up this jigsaw solving the
puzzle of why the person has died
do you remember how it made you feel on
that first time dealing with the with
the body
that was very stressful very worrying
for two reasons one is I didn't want to
make a mistake but secondly I knew if I
was going to continue and progress to my
careers I wanted to as a forensic
pathologist I had to be able to do this
it was I actually going to be able to
get over that sense of
destruction that sense of violation of
another human being
that was definitely there when I came to
do that first examination so I didn't
sleep much the night before was very
worried it took me a long time to
actually do the examination took a long
time during that day but at the end of
it there were the the realization
that my Fascination for the human body
how it all fitted together how it all
worked what it looked like perhaps when
things began to go wrong was still there
and was still really important and
really really fascinated me
I'm gonna ask several questions which
are probably like those annoying
questions everyone asks you
um I can probably answer them then so
when you perform a note say how do you
deal with the smell of a dead body what
smell is there a no smell there's a lot
of smell but when you've done 23 000
autopsies you don't notice the smell or
you don't take any notes of there's
other things that much more important
what you're dealing with what's it feel
like what does it look like what's the
touch how's it cutting what's it what is
it telling me about this person's life
and their death the smell is is a
transient thing it it's not there for
any significant period of time I mean
the people who come into the the autopsy
room are really worried about the smell
but it simply is not an important
component in 99.99 of postmortem
do you listen to music when you work no
no I work in Silas some of my colleagues
have music on
um some have heavy rocks some have light
rock some have classical I like to work
in silence because I want to focus so I
mean we'll often find that as in
operating theaters a lot of Surgeons
like to have some sort of Music on to
lighten the atmosphere I don't I need to
focus you know what I'm doing I think is
so important for what that family and
Society generally I need to concentrate
what are the most common causes of death
you deal with
heart disease by far that's the thing
that kills most people then respiratory
disease fortunately now fewer people are
smoking
um and we're beginning to see the tail
off of diseases associated with
cigarette smoking but what vaping is
going to do we still don't know remember
it took us 30 40 50 years to work out
that cigarette smoking was as dangerous
so vaping at the minute okay said to be
fine but we'll see in years to come
whether there are any long-term diseases
if we're thinking about accidental
deaths probably drugs
with or without road traffic accidents
if we're thinking about murders
it's stabbings stabbing stabbing
stabbings they are the commonest cause
of death and the person most likely to
stab you is a friend or a relative
so you worked on some very high profile
crime cases which ones stood out for you
and why
well not the high profile ones funnily
enough the high profile ones are high
profile because it's a famous person
um you know there's lots of um
celebrities die but they die often in
rather banal and boring ways you know if
I'm going to pick on cases that are
important it's cases where I'm dealing
with people privately and helping them
through their grief not the major
world trade Princess Diana they're
important
but they're not the ones that stick with
me as part of my Professional Pride
talking about Princess Diana's case
because I'm I'll have to ask about it
what can you say about it what kind of
your viewers your I'll take over
I wasn't the pathologist who performed
the autopsy on Princess Diana or Dodie
Alford that was a colleague of mine
um who was the pathologist on call that
day I was called in as part of an expert
review team this was a year 18 months
maybe two years later on this team was
put together because the conspiracy
theories just went on and on and on and
you know social media was beginning to
develop and it was just getting worse
and worse and it was felt there really
really needed to be a proper
investigation into what had happened in
the alma tunnel on that night now three
people died that night at Princess Diana
dodiel fired and a man caught Henry Paul
who was the driver and in many ways
Henry Paul is the most important because
he was the one driving the Mercedes he
was the one that was
possibly the cause of the accident or
certainly did things that contributed to
or failed to prevent the accident so his
post-mortem was most important
but in the whole analysis
when we look at the injuries that Diana
had they were very minor injuries
in her left lung a tear of a relatively
small blood vessel
now
when I look at that injury and the
knowledge that she was actually alive
and talking when the first people
stopped these were people just passing
by one of whom happened to be a doctor
she was talking when they first saw her
um stuck down the back of the seat
behind Trevor Reese Jones who was her
security officer he had just managed he
realized what was going on and just
managed to get his seat belt plugged in
before the impact with the central
reservation of that tunnel now Mercedes
are fantastic cars Mercedes have
passenger compartments designed to cope
with 60 70 mile an hour impacts they
have crumple zones front and back but
inside the passenger box if you wear
your seatbelt
you should still be safe or relatively
uninjured and the reason that three
people died was that Henry Paul and
Dodie didn't wear their seatbelts so
when they hit the
Central reservation
Dodie Al fired hit the back of Henry
Paul's seat with a weight of about four
elephants
and so he hit the back of the seat and
completely crashed on report against the
steering wheel Trevor Reese Jones had
his seat belt on and so when Diana who
wasn't wearing a seatbelt him she was
partially
protected by him the injury that she had
was one of these hidden injuries
she was okay she was chatting she I
think she had a broken arm she had some
other minor injuries but you know not
immediately life-threatening they had to
get Trevor Reese Jones out of the
vehicle he was severely injured and had
to be got out first and she was okay it
was only on the journey to hospital that
her condition tipped from being
increasingly unstable to serious and she
had a cardiac arrest and when they got
her to the hospital major thoracic
surgery couldn't save her but if only
she'd worn a seatbelt she would I'm sure
still be alive today
what's your view on all the conspiracy
theorists surrounding her guests there's
nothing that I've seen that was a
deliberate attempt and I've examined
hundreds and hundreds of road traffic
accidents and this is a tragic one it
killed
um Princess Diana it killed two other
people as well but there's nothing
different about this other than
and if if I was talking about someone Mr
Mrs Joe Snooks who had a crash on the m6
and they weren't wearing their seat
belts so I'd say well they contribute to
it significantly themselves by not
wearing the seatbook
you come in contact with death every day
do you think it changed your view on
this
well I've just had my 70th birthday so
I'm beginning to look at death in a
different way because I'm now 70.
although hopefully it's still a long way
away but
um yes I mean so many of the deaths
that I've seen have been
unreasonable and that life shouldn't
have ended in the way that it did people
have taken drugs you
four pills of the party oh I haven't
picked one and a blue one and they take
them and they think it's a hoot and then
they're dead or they're on a ventilator
in hospital and then they die I find
them very very sad but if I if I do see
someone who's
90 a hundred who's lived a good life and
who's
physical skills are just gradually
fading away
then maybe that's a good death
there is obviously a lot of new
technology I was wondering how the new
technologies changing the world of
forensics
well there's all sorts of Technologies
coming up now in medicine
the dissection of the human being has
stayed pretty much the same since the
1500s actually even going back before
that when Julius Caesar had a postmortem
after being stabbed in the Forum uh you
know there are 23 stab wounds and the
the man who did the postmortem said it
was the second one that killed him which
is all good Quincy stuff as far as I'm
concerned but it stayed pretty much the
same because the human body hasn't
changed yet the heart's still on the
left-hand side you still have two lungs
one brain two arms two legs all these
things have stayed the same so the
techniques for examine it have stayed
pretty much the same but what we have
now in clinical medicine coming in when
I was really beginning my training are
CT scans MRI scans other ways of looking
inside the body without actually opening
it up this isn't my case it's a case
that belonged to a colleague of mine and
it sort of typifies in a sense forensic
medicine and where we are
a man is found severely injured by the
side of the road he's got a head injury
it's assumed because of his lifestyle
which was a bit itinerant that he's
probably been hit by the wing mirror of
a lorry that's come past him on the road
and just dinged him on the side of the
head no chance of tracing that Lorry
there's no paint there's no other things
about that Lorry that you could possibly
identify he goes into hospital he has a
CT scan he has quite significant
head and brain surgery where the
fractured skull
the bit of the skull that's fractured is
actually cut out which is what the
surgeons do if it's pushing in on the
brain
and it's thrown away
a bit later on someone says oh no
actually we think he may have been hit
by a hammer
but by this time he's dead
and the bit of skull has been disposed
of as clinical waste using the CT scan
of the original injury they were able to
look at the skull as it was and using 3D
printing they were able to reconstruct
the fracture in the skull and match it
with a hammer
and prove that this man had actually
been murdered
and not killed by an unfortunate accent
and someone is in prison serving time
for that murder so these techniques the
forensic techniques building with modern
Digital Image techniques using them also
to examine the body in
TV series but also in real life just
takes us that step further forward
what would you say is the best part of
your job
the best part of my job is when I can
communicate to
families because they're the ones
whether it's been a murder or whether
it's been an accent or a drug overdose
or a sudden collapse of natural causes
they're the ones that are left bereft
they're the ones that are wondering what
happened and people have to go through
this grieving process to put it in its
place
so that they can carry on with their
life and an understanding of how and why
their relative died is a part it's not
the whole it's a part you know where do
you begin to say your son has been
stabbed in a pub fight and if that
person hadn't had the knife or the knife
had been half a centimeter one one way
or the other he would be in hospital
perhaps having had the serious operation
but he would be alive it's that that
communication is both the best and the
worst component of this job but it's
that part that I can give and if I give
it correctly then they can move on with
an understanding
and I probably cleaned up close to three
or four hundred different scenes where
people have disemboweled themselves put
a knife in their stomach and and kept
themselves open while they're alive even
one gentleman decided to take some
scissors and cut his intestines while
he'd done it and throw them in the bath